welcome to this video I'm playing genius
2440 no 2544 ok so what do we get
Caesarion ok with is six ok I usually
recommend g3 or C 3 here to my students
as simple ways to play so I can play
like that myself why not go to practice
what you preach at least to some extent
yeah I mean I don't need to play all the
openings that I think are appropriate
for people to play but I'm never
recommending anything that I really
think is bad or that I then I wouldn't
really yeah be comfortable with playing
myself ok so that being said what what
what am i doing against the knight on d5
hmm ok i'm preparing Knight c3 maybe I
can play it I could have played it
immediately but this doesn't look so bad
PM threatening d4 to d5 yeah and I mean
threatening it's maybe a strong word but
yeah let me I can do this now right i
can go d5 and i want but i have a couple
of other options right over to e4 for
example it's not a bad idea
d5 takes as Bishop d7
I wonder this is a bit bit lame or that
maybe this for 494 queen age five okay
now he's taking okay of course i'm not
i'm opening at him I'm much better
developed so ok now ok d5 on 94 94 is
good I guess
so queen age five then rookie won this
kind of thing Liam maybe it's got f5
it's a bit of an ugly-looking move but
he might have to play that he didn't
play it okay so look to the 14 d 45 okay
but now okay so d5 I guess huh t5 he
takes Queen g6 should be this kind of
thing nothing no not two not playing to
passively there's also 8545 huh 25
Knight f6 check this is even more
aggressive looking question is is it
good look 25 Quinn two is six hmm okay
let's do this then threatening
intermediate made this got deform I
totally forgot d4 d5 to d4 okay and then
I should have taken on d5 with the rook
I mean that would have been just good
for white but I thought Queen g6 is
stronger but he has got a deform no I
didn't play that huh Wow okay so i can
go look g5 now amongst others all night
f six wins wins the exchange yeah I mean
check no reason not to can even play the
intermediate move Bishop g5 but now it
should be shot d5 check my it's not
necessary i can just stay here
yeah thats that looks like but I can
check on d4 yeah Bishop d 494 look T for
Queen D for Bishop e7 that must be must
be excellent but I can I can also play
Bishop g5 check by the way after which
she has to go to evade and then like
Queen h7 our see a shank I don't leave
that one bid can I di can also check
that's exactly that's made body making
of a it was a bit tougher but i still
think Queen h7 should win yeah it does
wind yeah even threatening twin GA check
made and no move I can do this but this
is certainly winning somehow okay plus
for the engine and this is Genesis is
leading to a maid or corn okay check yes
to loses everything yeah okay so let's
have a look I think it was an
interesting interesting game castles
this is a bit slow what he's doing here
but I mean not fatal or anything but
it's a bit it's a bit slow okay Bishop
t2 probably Knight c3 is also not bad
but I had this idea to recapture with
the bishop and try to use it on the
diagonal b6 and now we are k92 d5 was
the simple solution something like this
and now just a rook to d1 maybe this is
better i don't know it's that's a clean
way to do it but i like the idea to put
the night only forward which is
immediately stopped and okay this this
is a bad mouth ham this is much stronger
and then d hive
hmm yeah this is much stronger the
problem is said here this f5 who is
always quite quite okay firm and not
here probably but he could have played
like here if he goes and f5 and maybe it
doesn't get it in so easily this is a
very interesting suggested by stockfish
the ideas it after f5 TX takes d5 wide
is winning which is not forced I mean
black can do something else interesting
yeah okay the other line just d5 instead
of 92 was once was cleaner but this is
still interesting yeah d 5 is winning
him yeah it's given by winning a battle
comp and it just just a bit too much
okay interesting this is actually losing
due to defy yeah I suspected that much
that defy overlooked them or simply and
I should have just played this one which
is good for white and simple to play the
engine gives this as winning which is
kind of nice what is this move takes
bishop change and yeah yeah yeah no move
no move ok this is checkmate quite easy
after that I'm will be the queen and
then what else is there i can can give
the Queen like that but that's also
winning Wow 95 rather what that's strong
ok I played Queen g6 and relatively not
so quickly but I really I totally
overlooked d4 completely and yeah ok
after that yeah why twins but deform I
have no move really it's a it's not it's
not apparent what I should play
before is hanging and I have no move
that would have been a cold shower yeah
but after that i'm really excited easily
winning the comp gives this is even
stronger yeah okay and once you see the
move from friends checkmate and after
the capture check checkmate you're
meeting him I was even better but ok
that wins sir check check that wins as
well that's just a little bit more
complicated ok well thank you for
watching